the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
welcome back I hope you didn't spend
time doing six triple o to problem sets
while eating turkey it's not recommended
for digestion but I hope you're ready to
go back into diving into material and
since it's been a week since we got
together let me remind you of what we
were doing we were looking at the issue
of how to understand experimental data
data could come from a physical
experiment we had the example of
measuring the spring constant of a
linear spring could come from biological
data could come from social data and
what we looked at was the idea of how do
we actually fit models to that data in
order to understand them so what I want
to do is I want to start with that
high-level reminder of what we were
after I want to do about a five-minute
recap of what we were doing last time
because it has been a while and then
we're going to talk about how do you
actually validate models that you're
fitting to data to understand are they
really good fits or not and if you
remember I know you spent all your time
thinking about 60 or below - if you
remember I left you with a puzzle where
I fit data to some hour sorry fit models
to some noisy data and there was a
question of did the model really have an
order 16 fit alright so what are we
trying to do remember our goal is to try
and model experimental data and really
what we want to do is have a model that
both explains the phenomena underlying
what we see gives us a sense of what
might be the underlying physical
mechanism the underlying social
mechanism and can let us make
predictions about the behavior in new
settings in the case of my spring being
able to predict what will the
displacement be when I actually put a
different weight on it than something I
measured or if you want to think of from
a design perspective working the other
direction and saying I don't want my
spring to deflect more than this amount
under certain kinds of weights so how do
I use the model to tell me what the
spring constant should be for the spring
I want in that case so we want to be
able to predict behavior new settings
last piece we know is that if the data
was perfect this is easy but it ain't
it's always going to be noise there's
always going to be experimental
uncertainty and so I really
to account for that uncertainty when I
fit that model and well sometimes I'll
have theories that will help hook says
models of Springs are linear in some
cases I don't and in those cases I want
to actually try and figure out what's
the best model to fit even when I don't
know what the theory tells me okay so
quick recap what did we use to solve
this we said if we got a set of observed
values my spring case for different a
displace our for different masses I
measure the displacements those
displacements my observed values and if
I had a model that would predict what
the displacement should be I can measure
how good the fit is by looking at that
expression right there the sum of the
squares of the differences between the
observed and the predicted data as I
said we could use other measures we
could use a first-order and absolute
value the square is actually really
handy because it makes the solution
space very easy to deal with which we'll
get to in a second so given observed
data get a prediction I can use some a
squared differences to measure how good
the fit is and then the second piece is
I now want to find what's the best way
to predict the data what's the best
curve that fits the data it's the best
model for predicting the values and we
suggested last time we'll focus on
mathematical expressions polynomials
professor Guttag is so excited about
polynomial expressions he's throwing
laptops on the floor please don't do
that to your laptop we're going to fit
polynomials to these expressions and it
since the polynomials have some
coefficients the game is basically how
do I find the coefficients of the
polynomial that minimized that
expression and that we said was an
example of linear regression so let me
just remind you what linear regression
says simple example case of the spring
I'm going to fit a degree one polynomial
so that is something of the form y is ax
plus B a and B are the free variables
the parameters I can change and the idea
is for every X in the case of my spring
for every mass I'm going to use that
model to predict what's the displacement
measure the differences and find the
thing that minimizes so I just want to
find values of a and B that let me
predict values that minimize that
expression
as I suggested you could solve this you
could write code to do it it's a neat
little piece of code to write but
fortunately pylab provides that for you
and I just want to give you the
visualization of what we're doing here
and then we're going to look at examples
I'm going to try and find the best line
it's represented by two values a and B I
could represent all possible lines in a
space that has one access with a values
and the other access with B values every
point in that plane defines a line for
me now imagine a surface laid over this
two-dimensional space where the value or
the height of the surface is the value
of that objective function at every
point don't worry about computing at all
but just imagine I could do that and by
the way one of the nice things about
doing sum of squares is that surface
always has a concave shape and now the
idea of linear regression is I'm going
to start at some point on that surface
and I'm just going to walk downhill
until I get to the bottom there will
always be one bottom one point and once
I get to that point that a and B value
tell me the best line so it's called
linear regression because I'm linearly
walking downhill on this space now I'm
doing this for line with two parameters
a B because it's easy to visualize if
you're a good mathematician even if
you're not you can generalize this to
think about arbitrary dimensions so a
fourth-order surface in a five
dimensional space for example would
solve a cubic example of this that's the
idea of linear regression that's what
we're going to use to actually figure
out to find the best solution so here
was the example I used gave you set of
data and about three slides are going to
tell you where the data came from but I
give you set of data we could fit the
best line to this using that linear
regression idea and again last piece of
reminder I'm going to use poly fit from
pylab it just solves that linear
regression problem I give it a set of X
values I give a corresponding set of Y
values need to be the same number in
each case and I give it a dimension and
in this case one says find the best
fitting line
it will produce that and return it as a
tuple which I'll store under the name
model one and I could plot it out so
just remind you Polly fit will find the
best fitting and dimensional surface and
being that last parameter there and
return it and in a second we're going to
use Polly Val which will say given that
model and a set of X values predict what
the Y value should be apply them okay so
I fit the line what do you think good
fit not so much right pretty ugly I mean
you can see it's probably the best and
not probably it is the best fitting line
it's sort of annual accounts for the
variation on either side of it but it's
not a very good fit so then the question
is well why not try fitting a
higher-order model so I could fit a
quadratic that is a second-order model y
equals ax squared plus BX plus C run the
same code plot that out and I get that
as the linear model
there's the quadratic model least by I
looks a lot better right it looks like
it's following that data reasonably well
okay if I can fit a linear model I can
fit a quadratic model what about higher
order models what about a fourth order
model an eighth order model a 64th order
model how do I know which one's going to
be best so for that I'm going to remind
you of the last thing we used and then
we're going to start talking about how
to use it further which is if we try
fitting higher order polynomials do we
get a better fit and to do that we need
to measure what it means for the data to
fit if I don't have any other
information for example if my don't have
a theory that tells me this should be
linear in the case of hook then the best
way to do it is to use what's called the
coefficient of determination R squared
it's a scale independent thing which is
good by scale independent I mean if I
take all the data and stretch it out
this will still give me back the same
value in terms of the fit so it doesn't
depend on the size of the data and what
it does is it basically tells me with
the value between 0 and
on how well does this model fit the data
so just to remind you in this case the
Y's are the measured values the peas are
the predicted values that's what my
model is saying for each one of these
cases and Mew down here is the mean or
the average of the measured values the
way to think about this is this top
expression here well that's exactly what
I'm trying to minimize right so it's
giving me an estimate or a measure of
the error in the estimates between what
the model says and what I actually
measure in the denominator down here
basically tells me how much does the
data vary away from the mean value now
here's the idea if in fact I can get
this to zero I can get a model that
completely accounts for all the
variation in the estimates that's great
says the model has fit perfectly and
that means this is zero so this R value
or r-squared value is one on the other
hand if this is equal to that and
meaning that all of the variation in the
estimates accounts for none of the
variation in the data then this is one
and this goes to zero and so the idea is
that an r-squared value is close to one
is great it says the model is a good fit
to the data our squared value is getting
closer to zero not so good okay so I ran
this fitting models of order two four
eight and sixteen now you can see that
model two that's the Green Line here
that's the one that we saw before it's
basically a parabolic kind of art it
kind of follows the data pretty well but
if I look at those r-squared values wow
look at that
order sixteen fit accounts for all but
three percent of the variation in the
data it's a great fit and you can see
you can see how it follows it actually
goes through most but not quite all of
the data points so it's following them
pretty well okay so if that's the
the order 16 fit is really the best fit
should we just use it and I left you
last time with that quote that says from
your parents right your mother telling
you just because you can do something
doesn't mean you should do something
I'll leave it at that same thing applies
here why are we building the model
remember I said two reasons one is to be
able to explain the phenomena and the
second one is to be able to make
predictions so I want to be able to
explain the phenomena in the case of a
spring was things like it's linear and
that gives me a sense of a linear
relationship between compression and
force in this case a sixteenth order
pump model what kind of physical process
has an order 16 variation yeah sounds a
little painful so maybe not a great
insight into them into the the process
the second reason is I want to be able
to predict future behavior of this
system in the case of the spring I put a
different weight on that I've done
before I want to predict what the the
displacement is going to be I've done a
set of trials for an FDA approval of a
drug now I want to predict the effect of
a treatment on a new patient how do I
use the model to help me with that one
that maybe not so good currently I want
to predict the outcome of an election
maybe those models need to be fixed from
at least what happened the last time
around but I need to be able to make the
prediction so another way of saying it
is a good model both explains the
phenomena
unless me take the predictions okay so
let's go back then to our example and
before I do it let me tell you where
that data came from I actually built
that data by looking at another kind of
physical phenomena and was a lot of them
things that follow a parabolic arc so
for example comets any particle under
the influence of a uniform gravitational
field follows a parabolic arc just why
Halley's Comet gets really close for a
while and then goes away off into the
solar system and comes back around my
favorite example I'm biased on this and
I know you all know which team I root
for but there's Tom Brady throwing a
pass against the Pittsburgh Steelers
senator of mass of the past follows a
nice parabolic arc even in design you
see parabolic arcs in lots of places
they have nice properties in terms of
distress our disbursement of loads and
forces which is why architects like to
use them so here's how I generated the
data I wrote a little function actually
I didn't professor Guttag did but I
borrowed it that took in three
parameters a B and C ax squared plus BX
plus C I gave it a set of X values those
are the independent measurements the
things along the horizontal axis and
notice what I did I generated values
given an a B and C for that equation and
then I added in some noise so random-dot
Gauss takes a mean and a standard
deviation and it generates noise
following that bell-shaped curve or that
Gaussian distribution so the zero says
it's zero mean meaning there's no bias
it's going to be equally likely to be
above or below the value positive or
negative but 35 is a pretty good
standard deviation this is putting a lot
of noise into the data and then I just
added that into Y values the rest of
this you can see it's simply going to
write it into a file a set of x and y
values but this will generate given a
value for a B and C data from a
parabolic arc with noise added to it and
in this case I took it as a y equals 3x
squared and then B and C or 0 and that's
how I generated ok what I want to do I
want to see how well this model actually
predicts behavior so one of the ways I
could do it to say are the question I
want to ask is whoa if I generated the
data from a degree 2 polynomial a
quadratic why in the world is the 16th
order polynomial the best fit puzzle so
let's test it out I'm going to give 3
sorry 4
I can't count for different degrees
order to order for order 8 order 16 and
I've generated 2 different data sets
using exactly that code just ran it
twice it's going to have slightly
different
always because the noise is going to be
different in each case but they're both
coming from that a y equals 3x squared
equation and the code here basically
says I'm going to take those two
datasets and basically get the X and y
values out and then fit models so remind
you Jen Fitz takes in a collection of x
and y values and a list or tuple of
degrees and for each degree finds using
poly fit the best model so models one
will be for models for order two four
eight and sixty and similarly down here
I'm going to do the same thing but using
the second data set and I'm going to fit
again a set of models and then I'll
remind you test fits she saw last time I
know it's a while ago basically takes a
set of models a corresponding set of
degrees x and y values and says for each
model and that degree measure how well
that model meets the fit using that
r-squared value so test fits is going to
get us back a set of our squared values
alright with that in mind I've got the
code here let's run it and there we go
I'm going to run that code ah I got two
fits looks good let's look at the values
so there's the first data set all right
the green line still is doing not a bad
job the purple line boy is fitting it
really well and again notice here's the
best fit that's amazing that is
accounting for all but point four
percent of the variation in the data
great fit order sixty came from an order
to thing alright what about the second
data set Oh
grump it also says order sixteen fit is
the best fit not quite as good it
accounts for all but about two percent
of the variation again the green line
the red line do okay but in this case
again that purple line is still the best
fit
so I still got this puzzle but I didn't
quite test what I wanted right said I
want to see how well it predicts new
behavior here what I did was I took two
data sets fit the model and I got two
different fits one for each data set
they both fit well for order 16 but
they're not quite right okay so best
fitting model is still order 16 but we
know it came from an order to polynomial
so how can I really get a handle on
seeing how good this model is well what
we're seeing here is coming from
training error or another way of saying
it is what we're measuring is how well
does the model perform on the data from
which it was learned how well do I fit
the model to the training data I want a
small training error if you think about
it go back to the first example when I
fit a line to this data it did not do
well that was not a good model when I
fit a quadratic it was pretty decent and
then it got better and better as I went
on so I certainly need at least a small
training error but it's to use the
mathematical terms a necessary but not
sufficient condition to get a great
model I need a small training error but
I really want to make sure that the
model is capturing what I'd like and so
for that I want to see how well does it
do on other ghent data generated from
the same process whether it's weights on
Springs different comments besides
Haley's comets different voters than
those surveyed when we tried to figure
out what's going to happen in an
election and I'm set up to do that by
using a really important tool called
validation or cross-validation let me
set the stage and then we're going to do
the example I'm going to get a set of
data I'm going to fit a model to it
actually different models different
degrees different kinds of models to see
how well they work I want to see how
well they predict behavior under other
data than that from which I did the
training so I could do that right here I
could generate the models from one data
set but test them on the other and so in
fact
I had one data set I built a set of
models for the verse data set I compared
how well it did on that data set but I
could now apply it to the second data
set how well does that account for that
data set and similarly take the models I
built for the second data set and see
how well they predict the points from
the first data set what do I expect I
certainly expect that the testing error
is likely to be larger than the training
error because I train on one set of data
and that means this ought to be a better
way to think about how well does this
model generalize how well does it
predict other behavior besides what I
started with so here's the code I'm
going to use it's pretty straightforward
all I want to draw your attention to
here is the member models one I built by
fitting models of degree 2 4 8 and 16 to
the first data set and I'm going to
apply those models to the second data
set X Val's - and my Val's - and
similarly I'm going to take the models
built for the second data set and test
them on the first data set to see how
well they fit I know you're eagerly
anticipating as I've been setting this
up for a whole week alright let's look
at what happens when I do this I'm going
to run it and then we'll look at the
examples so if I go back over to Python
and this code was distributed earlier if
you want to go play with it yourself
should be the right place to do it I am
going to run that code ah now I get
something a little different and in fact
if I go look at it
here's model one applied to data set two
and we can both eyeball it and look at
the numbers eyeballing it there's that
green line still generally following the
form of this pretty well what about the
Purple Line the order 16 degree and
member that's the purple line from model
1 from training set 1 Wow misses a bunch
of points pretty badly and in fact look
at the r-squared values order 2 and
order four pretty good fit accounts for
all but about 14 13 percent of the data
look what happened to the agrees 16
threw up some degrees 16 fit way down at
point 7 last time around it was 0.997
high and what about the other direction
taking the model built from the second
data set testing it on the first data
set again notice nice fit for degree 2
and 4 not so good
for degree 16 and just to give you a
sense of this I'm going to go back there
is the model in one case there is the
model in the other case you can see the
modeler that accounts for variation in
one doesn't account for the variation
and the other when I look at an order 60
fit okay so what this says is something
important now I can see in fact if I
look back at this if I were just looking
at the coefficient of determination this
says in order to predict other behavior
I'm better off with an order 2 or maybe
order 4 polynomial those are our squared
values are both the same I happen to
know it's order 2 because that's where I
generated it from but that's a whole lot
better than order 16 and what you're
seeing here is an example of something
that happens a lot is statistics and in
fact I would suggest is often misused in
fitting data to statistical samples it's
called overfitting and what it means is
I let there be too many degrees of
freedom in my model too many free
parameters and what it's fitting isn't
just the
lying process it's also fitting to the
noise message I want you to take out of
this part of the lecture is if we only
fit the model to training data and we
look at how well it does we could get
what looks like a great fit but we may
actually have come up with far too
complex a model order 16 instead of
order 2 and the only way you're likely
to detect that is to train on one test
set and test on a different and if you
do that it's likely to expose whether in
fact I have done a good job of fitting
or whether I have over fit to the data
there are lots of horror stories in the
literature especially from early days of
machine learning of people overfitting
to data and coming up with models that
they thought wonderfully predicted in
effect and then when it ran on new data
really get the big one alright so this
is something you want to try and stay
away from and the best way to do it is
to do validation you can see it here
right the upper left is my training data
data set 1 there's the set of models
this is now taking that and applying it
to a different data set from the same
process and notice for the degree 2
polynomial the coefficient of
determination 0.86 now 0.87 the fact
it's slightly higher is just accident
but it's really about the same level
it's doing the same kind of job on the
training data and on the test data on
the other hand degrees 60 coefficient of
determination is a wonderful point 9 9 6
here and a pretty awful point 6 9 9 down
there and that's a sign that's we're not
good shape when in fact our coefficient
of determination drops significantly
when we try and handle new data ok so
why do we get a better fit on the
training data with a higher order model
but then do less well when we're
actually handling new data or another
way of saying it is if I started out
with in the case of that data a linear
model it didn't fit well and then I got
to a quadratic model why didn't that
quadratic model still say the best
why was it the case that as I added more
degrees of freedom I did better or
another way of asking it is can I
actually get a worse fit to training
data as I increase the model complexity
and I see at least one negative head
shake thank you you're right
I cannot let's look at why if I add in
some higher order terms and they
actually don't matter if I got perfect
data the coefficient will just be 0 the
fit will basically say this term doesn't
matter ignore it and that'll work in
perfect data but if the data is noisy
what the model is going to do is
actually start fitting the noise and
while it may lead to a better r-squared
value it's not really a better fit all
right let me show you an example of that
I'm going to fit a quadratic to a
straight line easy thing to do but I
want to show you the effect of
overfitting or adding in those extra
terms so let me say a little bit I'm
going to start off with just three sorry
three I'm doing that again today for
simple values 0 1 2 3 the Y values are
the same as X values so this is oo 1 1 2
2 3 3 they're all lying on a line but
I'm going to fit I'm going to plot them
out and then I'm going to fit a
quadratic why you get equals ax squared
plus BX plus C to this now I know it's a
line but I want to see what happens I've
fit a quadratic so I'm going to use poly
fit to fit a quadratic I'm going to
print out some data about it and then
I'm going to use poly Val to estimate
what those values should be plot them
out and then compute the r-squared value
and see what happens all right okay let
me set this up better what am i doing I
want to fit it to a line I know it's
aligned but I'm going to fit a quadratic
to it and what I'd expect is even though
there's an extra term there it shouldn't
matter so if I go to Python and I run
this I'm going to run exactly that
example ah look at that I equals 0 B is
1 C equals 0 look at the r-squared value
let me pull that together for you
it says in this perfect case there's
what I get the blue line is drawn
through the actual values the dotted red
line is drawn through the predicted
values they exactly line up and in fact
the solution it finds says that higher
order term coefficient 0 it doesn't
matter so what it found was y equals x I
know you're totally impressed I could
find a straight line but notice what
happened there I dropped or the system
said you don't need the higher order
term wonderful r-squared value okay
let's see how well it predicts let's add
in one more point out at 20 so this is 0
1 2 3 that's 0 1 2 3 I'm going to add 20
in there so it's oo 1 1 2 2 3 3 20 20
gain I can estimate using the same model
so I'm not recomputing the model the
model I predicted from using those first
set of 4 points I can get the estimated
Y values plot those out and again
compute the r-squared value here and
even adding that point in there's the
line and guess what perfectly predicts
it no big surprise so it says in the
case of perfect data adding the higher
order terms isn't going to cause a
problem the system will say coefficients
are 0 that's all I need alright now
let's go back in and add in just a tiny
bit of noise right there whoa 1 1 2 2 &
3 3 point 1 so I've got a slight
deviation in the Y value there again I
can plot them I'm going to fit a
quadratic to them I'm going to print out
some information about it and then get
the estimated values using that new
model to see what it should look like
I'm not going to run out I'm just going
to show you the result I get a really
good r-squared value and there's the
equation it comes up with yeah not so
bad right
it's almost y equal X but because of
that little bit of noise there there's a
small second-order term here and a
little constant term down there the Y
squared value is really pretty good and
if you really squint and look carefully
at this you'll actually see there's a
little
bit of a deviation between the red and
the blue line it under shoots so I over
shoots there under shoots here but it's
really pretty close
alright so am I just whistling in the
dark here what's the difference well now
let's add in that extra point and what
happens so again I'm now taking the same
set of points zero zero one one two two
three and three point one I'm going to
do 2020 using the model I captured from
fitting to that first set I want to see
what happens here
crap oh sorry you didn't say that
darn drat pick up some other word
shouldn't surprise you write a small
variation here is now causing a really
large variation up there and this is why
in the ideal case overfitting is not a
problem because the coefficients get
zeroed out but even a little bit of
noise can cause a problem now I'll grant
you we set this up deliberately to show
a big effect it here but a three percent
error in one data point it's causing a
huge problem when I get further out on
this curve and by the way there's the
r-squared value is 0.7 doesn't do a
particularly good job okay so how would
I fix this well what if I had simply
done a first degree fit same situation
but say fit and align to this rather
than fitting a quadratic remember my
question was what the harm of fitting a
higher-order model if the coefficients
will be zeroed out we've seen they won't
be zeroed out but if I were just to have
fit aligned to this exactly the same
experiment oh oh one one two two three
and three point one twenty and twenty
now you can see it still does a really
good job of fitting and the r-squared
value is 0.99 eight eight so again
fitting the right level of model the
noise doesn't cause nearly as much of a
problem and so just to pull that
together basically it says the
predictive ability of the first order
model is much better than the second
order model and that's why in this case
I would want
use that first order model so take-home
message and then we're going to amplify
this if I pick an overly complex model I
have the danger of overfitting to the
training data overfitting meaning that
I'm not only fitting the underlying
process I'm fitting the noise I get an
order 16 model as the best fit when it's
in fact an order to model it was
generating it that increases the risk
that it's not going to do well with new
data
not what I like I want to be able to
predict what's going to go on well here
on the other hand so that would say boy
just stick with the simplest possible
model but there's a trade-off here and
we already saw that when I've tried to
fit a line to a data that was basically
quadratic I didn't get a good fit so I'd
want to find the balance an
insufficiently complex model won't
explain the data well an overly complex
model will over fit to the training data
so I'd like to find the place where the
model is as simple as possible but still
explains the data and I can't resist the
quote from Einstein that captures it
pretty well everything should be made as
simple as possible but not simpler in
the case of where I started it should be
fit a quadratic because it's the right
fit but don't fit more than that because
it's getting overly complex now how
might we go about finding them the right
model we're not going to dwell on this
but here's a standard way in which you
might do it start with a low order model
gain take that data fit a linear model
to it look at not only the r-squared
value but see how well it accounts for
new data increase the order of the model
repeat the process and keep doing that
until you find a point at which a model
does a good job both on the training
data and on predicting new data the
natura starts to fall off that gives you
a point where you might say there's a
good sized model in the case of this
data of whether I would have stopped at
a quadratic or it might have used a
cubic or a quartic depends on the values
but I certainly wouldn't have gone much
beyond that and this is one way if you
don't have a theory to drive you to
think about how do I actually fit the
model the way I would like
let's go back to where we started I
still have one more big topic to do and
we still have a few minutes left oh
let's go back to where we started
Hookes law there was the data from
measuring displacements of a spring as I
added different weights to the bottom of
the spring and there's the linear fit
it's not bad
there's the quadratic fit and it's
certainly got a better r-squared value
though that could be just fitting to the
noise but you actually can see I think
that that green curve probably does a
better job of fitting the data well wait
a minute even though the quadratic fit
is tighter here Hookes says this is
linear so what's going on well this is
another place where you want to think
about your model and I'll remind you in
case you don't remember your physics
unless we believe that Hooke was wrong
this should tell us something and in
particular Hookes law says the model
holds until you reach the elastic limit
of the spring you stretch a slinky too
far it never springs back you go beyond
that elastic limit and that's probably
what's happening right up there through
here it's following that linear
relationship up at this point I've
essentially broken the spring the
elastic limit doesn't hold anymore and
so really in this case I should probably
fit different models to different
segments and there's a much better fit
linear through the first part and
another linear line once I hit that
elastic limit how might I find this well
you could imagine a little search
process in which you try and find
where's the best place along here to
break the data into two sets fit linear
segments to both and get really good
fits for both examples and I raise it
because that's the kind of thing you've
also seen before you could imagine
writing code to do that search to find
that good fit okay that gives you a
sense than of why you want to be careful
about overfitting while you want to not
just look at the coefficient of
determination but see how well does this
predict behavior on new data sets
now suppose I don't have a theory like
hook to guide me can I still figure out
what's a good model to fit to the data
and the answer is you bet we're going to
use cross-validation to guide the choice
of the model complexity and I want to
show you two examples if the data sets
small we can use what's called leave one
out cross validation
I'll give you definition of that in a
second if the data sets bigger than that
we can use k-fold cross-validation I'll
give you a definition that a second or
just what's called repeated random
sampling but we can use this same idea
of validating on new data to try and
figure out whether the model is a good
model or not leave one out cross
validation this is written in pseudocode
but the idea is pretty simple I'm given
a data set it's not too large
the idea is to walk through a number of
trials number of trials equal to the
size of the data set and for each one
take the data set or a copy of it and
drop out one of the samples so leave one
out start off by leaving out the first
one then leaving out the second one
leaving out the third one for each one
of those training sets build the model
for example by using linear regression
and then test that model on this data
point that you left out so leave out the
first one build a model on all the other
ones and then see how well that model
predicts the first one leave out the
second one build a model using all them
about the second one see how well it
predicts the second one you just average
the results works when you don't have a
really large data set because it won't
take too long but it's a nice way of
actually testing validation if the data
sets a lot bigger you can still use the
same ideas use what's called K fold
divide the data set up into k equal
sized chunks leave one of them out use
the rest to build the model and then use
that model to predict that first chunk
you left out leave out the second chunk
keep doing it same idea but now with
groups of things rather than just
leaving out single data points right the
other way you can deal with it which has
a nice effect to it is to use what's
called repeated random
sampling gain start out with some data
set and what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to run through some number of
trials I'm going to call that K but I'm
also going to pick some number of random
samples from the data set usually I
think n is as I recall it as somewhere
between reserving 20 to 50% of the
samples out but the idea is again walk
over all of those K trials and in each
one pick out at random and elements for
the test set use the remainder as the
training set build the model on the
training set and then apply that model
to the test set so rather than doing k
fold where I select K in turn and keep
them this is just randomly selecting
which ones to pull out so I'm going to
show you one last example let's look at
that idea of I don't have a model here I
want to use this idea of
cross-validation to try and figure out
what's the best possible model and for
this I'm going to use a different set
data set
the data set here is I want a model or
the task here is I want to try and model
how the mean daily high temperature in
the US has varied over a lot of what is
that a 55 year period from 61 to 2050
I've got a set of data it's the mean
that they're sorry the daily high for
every day of the year through that
entire period and what I'm going to do
is I'm going to compute the means for
each year and plot them out and then I'm
going to try and fit models to them and
in particular I'm going to take a set of
different dimensionalities linear
quadratic cubic quartic and in each case
I'm going to run through a trial where I
train on one half of the data test on
the other there are gains that idea of
seeing how well it predicts other data
record the coefficient of determination
and do that and get out an average and
report what I get as the mean for each
of those values across each
dimensionality ok here we go
set a code that's pretty easy to see
hopefully you can just look at it and
grok it we start off with a boring class
whose professor Guttag suggests refers
to this lecture but it doesn't maybe a
boring lecture but it's not a boring
class this is a great class and boy
those jokes are really awful learn thing
but here we go
simple class that builds temperature
data
just reads in some information splits it
up and basically records the high for
the day and the year in which I got that
so for each day I've got a high
temperature for that day I'm going to
give you back the high temperature in
the year which is recorded because I
don't care whether it was in January and
June a little function that opens up a
file we've actually given that file if
you want to go look at it and simply
walks through the file reading it in and
returning a big list of all those data
objects okay then what I want to do is I
want to get the mean high temperature
for each year given that data I'm going
to set up a dictionary called years I'm
just going to run through a loop through
all the data points where in the
dictionary under that year so there's
the data point I use the method get'
year to get out the year at that point I
add in the high temperature
corresponding to that data point and I'm
using that nice little try except loop
I'll do that unless I haven't had
anything yet for this year in which case
this will fail and I'll simply store it
the first one in is a list so after I've
run through this loop in the dictionary
under the year I have a list of the high
temperatures for each day associated
with it excuse me and then I can just
compute the average that is for each
year in the years I get out that value I
add them up I get the length of the item
out and I store that in as the average
high temperature for the year now I can
plot it get the data get out the
information by computing those yearly
means run through a little loop that
basically in the X values puts in the
year in the Y values puts in the high
temperature and I can do a plot and if I
do that I get that I'll let you run this
yourself now this is a little bit
deceptive because of the scale I've used
here but nonetheless it shows in the US
over a 55 year period the mean high day
mister I mean daily high has gone from
about fifteen point five degrees Celsius
up to about seventeen and a half so it's
changed
now question is how could I model this
could I actually get a model that would
give me a sense of how this is changing
and that's what I'm going to use
cross-validation I'm going to run
through a number of trials ten trials
I'm going to try and fit four different
models linear quadratic cubic quartic
and for each of these dimensions I'm
going to get out a set of r-squared
value so I'm just going to initialize
that dictionary than empty lists and now
here's how I'm going to do this I've got
a list of X values those are years
they've got a list of Y values those are
average highest daily highs I'm going to
create a list of random samples so if
you haven't seen this before random dot
sample says given this iterator which
you can think of as the collection from
0 up to n minus 1 it's going to select
this many or half of them in this case
of those numbers at random so if I get a
0 up to 9 and I say pick 5 of them it
will at random give me back 5 of those
10 numbers with no duplicates ah that's
nice because now notice what I can do
I'm going to set up a training sort of
an x and y values for training set x and
y values for the test set and I'm just
going to run through a loop here where
if this index is in that list I'll stick
it in the training set otherwise I'll
stick it in the test set and then I just
return them so this is a really nice way
of at random just splitting the data set
into a test set and a training set and
then finally I can run over the number
of trials I want to deal with in each
case get a different training and test
set at random and then for each
dimension do the fit there's pauly fit
on the training x and training y values
and that dimension gives me back a model
I could just check to see how well the
training set des but I really want to
look at given that model how well does
Paul eval predict the test set right the
model will say here's what I expect is
the value
I'm going to compare that to the actual
values that I saw from the training set
computing that our squared value and
adding it in and then the last of this
just says I'll run this through a set of
examples okay
here's what happens if I do that I'm not
going to run it although the code will
run let me again remind you what I'm
doing I got a big set of data I'm going
to pick out at random subsets of it
build the model on one part test it on
the other part and if I run it I get a
linear fit quadratic fit cubic fit in a
quartic fit and here's the standard
deviation of those samples remember I
got on multiple trials I got ten trials
in this case so this gives me the
average over those trials and this tells
me how much they vary what can I
conclude from this well I would argue
that the linear fits probably the winner
here goes back to Einstein I want the
simplest possible model that accounts
for it and you can see it's got the
highest r-squared value which is already
a good sign it's got the smallest
deviation across the trials which says
it's probably a pretty good fit and it's
the simplest model so linear sounds like
a pretty good fit now why should we run
multiple data sets to test this I ran
ten trials of each one of these
dimensions why bother with it well
notice that those deviations I go back
to it here they're pretty good they're
about an order of magnitude less than
the actual mean which says they're
pretty tight but they're still
reasonable size and that suggests that
while there's good agreement the
deviations are large enough that you
could see a range of variation across
the trials so in fact if I had just run
one trial I could have been screwed
sorry
hosed sorry pick your favorite number
board here hose is a Canadian expression
in case you haven't seen it here are the
r-squared values or each trial of the
linear fit you can see the mean comes up
pretty well but notice if I'd only run
one trial and I happen to get that one
oh darn
that's a really low r-squared value and
we might have decided in this case a
different conclusion that the linear fit
was not a good fit so this is a way of
saying even in random sampling run
multiple trials because it lets you get
statistics on those trials as well as
statistics within each trial so within
each trial I'm doing a whole bunch of
different random samples I'm measuring
those values and then across those
trials I'm seeing what the deviation is
and I'm going to hope my machine comes
back because what I want to do is then
pull this together what have we done
something you're going to use we've seen
how you can use linear regression to fit
a curve to data 2d 3d 60 however big the
data set is it gives us a mapping from
the independent values to the dependent
values and that can then be used to
predict values associated with the
independent values that we haven't seen
yet that leads naturally to both a way
to measure it which is R squared but
especially to see that we want to look
at how well does that model actually
predict new data because that lets us
select the simplest model we can that
accounts for the data but predicts new
data in an effective way and that
complexity can either be based on theory
in the case of hook or in more likely
cases by doing cross validation to try
and figure out which one is the simplest
model that still does a good job of
predicting out of a out of data behavior
and with that we'll see you next time
you